leak of the supreme court's majority
draft opinion striking down roe versus
wade has congress still scrambling
democratic lawmakers want to codify a
law that would give legal abortion
protections for women just as roe did
for the last 50 years but for abortion
rights advocates this will not be an
easy task the issue is inflaming
passions on both sides rallies in
support of and in protest against the
supreme court's potential decision were
held across the country on friday
christina raffini is at the white house
with the latest christina good morning
to you
good morning jeff last year the white
house promised this whole of government
approach to protecting abortion rights
but so far that approach has come up
empty and now it seems they're running
out of time
we make them as big as this as well
while president biden toured a
manufacturing plant in ohio friday you
have an entire supply chain here
lawmakers in washington fielded
questions about how a potential overturn
of roe v wade could change the legal
landscape in a pregnancy i don't believe
that it is the state that should
intervene with its heavy hand
and make the decision i think those
decisions should be made by the elected
representatives of the people back in
the various states the draft majority
opinion leaked earlier this week and
published by politico is not final but
justice samuel alito argues the landmark
1973 decision was egregiously wrong from
the start and the issue should be
returned to the states we are in a range
of discussions with leadership in
congress so the range of members in
congress about the path forward and
what's possible senate democrats have
proposed a measure they hope to vote on
as soon as next week but need at least
60 votes to get it passed votes that so
far they don't have we are not
looking to compromise something as vital
as this and although the draft opinion
says it should only be applied to the
issue of abortion president biden says
other rights could be at risk this is
about a lot more than abortion what are
the next things that are going to be
attacked
the white house says president biden
would sign a bill that codified abortion
rights into law but keep in mind that
could be reversed if republicans take
back the majorities or by the supreme
court dana
all right christina thank you the